this is Claudia from Milan she is
covering for a secretary on maternity
leave Merrick is polish he is completing
a three-week computer programming
assignment andrew in the UK started
working on a construction site several
months ago after a long period of
unemployment these three Europeans have
one thing in common they are temporary
agency workers nowadays millions of
Europeans work through this flexible
form of employment claudia merrick and
andrew also share a common concern can
they be asked to work under less
favourable conditions than if they were
hired directly by the companies to do
the same job the answer is no a European
law protecting temporary agency workers
entitles them as a general rule to equal
treatment it gives them the same rights
and working conditions as their
counterparts who are hired directly by
the companies this applies to pay length
of working time breaks rest periods
holidays and anti-discrimination
measures agency workers have the same
needs as any other staff so they should
have access to any collective facilities
such as canteens childcare facilities
and transport services on an equal
footing with their colleagues their
access to training must also be improved
temporary agency workers should be given
an opportunity to find permanent
employment - so they must be informed of
any vacant posts in the company or
organisation where they work in some
countries it is the employers and
workers representatives who negotiate
the employment and working conditions of
agency workers but in all cases overall
protection must be ensured and of course
each EU country has its own regulations
what EU law does is to set common rights
that must be applied
better protection for agency workers
more flexibility for companies
you